but but listen listen we got we got all
these people snapping off
they're getting sick and tired of the
lockdowns joe biden saying the
lockdown's
not going to stop no he's well i'm sorry
he said we're going to listen to the
science and his science advisor says
what do you say six months then we got
bill gates and fauci saying 2022.
now we got this from the guardian the
world health organization warns covet 19
pandemic
is not necessarily the big one experts
tell
end-of-year media briefing that virus is
likely to become endemic and the world
will have to learn to live with it
now does that mean that we're all going
to chill out
reduce the lockdowns take some
precautions maybe get a vaccine
or does it mean we're locked down
forever i think it's locked on fire i
think
well no i mean they've shown that it
well now when i say it works
not that it actually helps in mitigating
whatever spread it works is in the fact
that
they can control you they know that they
can do that that's a thing that they can
do
they can shut everything down um and do
whatever it is that they want and that's
what they were allowed to do so i think
that is what people are going to see as
a new normal because
unfortunately 10 even a decade ago it's
just unreal could you just
imagine someone being like yeah there's
going to be this virus
that it's like a 99.9
survival rate and we're going to shut
not just this country down but multiple
countries there could you
we're just going to shut down the small
businesses and allow the big corporate
buddies
right well that will it will transfer
and you can still go out and dance for
biden
yeah most well and you can of course
protest for black lives if that's your
thing as well that's that's also on the
table but no like they recognize that it
works and the people that are in control
the for whatever reason the people that
we listen to whether they're health
expert or not i mean bill gates i mean
i'm always seeing him on tv lecturing
lecturing us about this issue as well
but that's what it is that they want
this is why i say like civil
disobedience man is like
i know i got called a conspiracy
theorist very early on in this pandemic
when i talked about like dude
if you idiots think that it's just gonna
be two weeks i'm sorry
we know that there's no such thing as a
temporary government program they're
going to kick the can
down the road again and they still
didn't listen i i i got i got to stop
here
and this misinformation or i should i
shouldn't say misinformation i should
say
you know how dare you criticize bill
gates
it is it is a long-standing tradition in
this country to turn to software
developers for their expertise in
epidemiology
now bill gates who who's more qualified
than to talk about a virus
than a guy who made a bunch of computer
programs
computer there's viruses on computers
different viruses there you go
virus same word right
i wonder how many like you know people
who hate me are gonna take that out of
context
anyway anyway look here here's here's
the main point with the story though
they're just saying it's going to get
worse right
you guys remember that v for vendetta
scene where the chancellor is like i
want them to know why they need us
and then it shows all the news clips
playing and there's like the guy in the
bar and he's watching the story
and he goes do you believe this bollocks
and like people are shaking their head
at it
so i see these stories where they're
like kovid we'll keep mutating it will
only get worse and we don't know if the
vaccine is going to help
and now we got we got a couple stories i
want to show you to exemplify this
the first one is is this one from the
new york times
small number of covid patients developed
severe psychotic
symptoms most had no history of mental
illness
and became psychotic weeks after
contracting the virus
cases are expected to remain rare but
are being reported worldwide
all right there's one more story i got
to show you but i got a question for
this when those people got bell's palsy
they said oh but only a few people got
bell's palsy from the vaccine it's not a
big deal
so a couple people get psychotic
symptoms and they think it's
it's you know major new york times
publish this story boom breaking
i see this story and at this point i'm
just like are you kidding me dude
they're saying covet causes blood clots
your
your feet scab up you know you can't
breathe infertility
your heart stops and you go psychotic it
does all these things calm
down man if that's true then we're in
serious trouble right but to be fair
okay maybe it is true that's why they're
all freaking out
okay but it kind of does feel like
they're just inundating with this stuff
and and that's exemplified by this next
story from abc news
nurse tests positive for covid19
shortly after getting vaccinated you
mean to tell me
they get they get the vaccine and then
eight days later they get sick and they
say
this scenario isn't unexpected here's
how it could have happened
maybe they already had the virus before
getting the vaccine but i'll tell you
what this story is
more fear i'm sorry the vaccine the why
is abc news telling us the vaccine
there are they're putting out the story
that questions whether the vaccine is
going to going to work
they want us terrified so that we just
just give in and say
do whatever you want government shut
everything down forever and let people
just wallow in it
that's exactly what they want but i mean
look this is why it was so important
that no matter where you were at on this
issue i mean i understand there was a
lot of people that were freaking out
early on like you didn't know much about
the vice
okay let's just say for the sake of
conversation though the numbers were
out coming out of south korea and even
china they said the same thing
uh believe them or not they they
actually said that's the same thing as
far as who it impacted
how deadly it actually it actually was
but that's why it was so important there
to say no like you had to do it then
because if you didn't do it then
you showed them you showed the state you
showed the uh whether it be local
governments the governors the every
congress
woman and man you showed them that
that's all that it takes
is to scare you that's all when do they
report good news wouldn't it be
fantastic news
for them to say yeah not mo
the vast and when i say vast majority of
people that catch this like it's not
even close like the
vast majority of that catch this will
never have to go to the hospital
and they will never get severely sick
that's not my opinion their own their
own data says
most importantly you brought up a very
important point before saying
that there's too many things going for
the elites for them to stop this
they're benefiting absolutely too much
and then also when you look at v for
vendetta it is
eerily eerily very similar to what's
happening right now and just to remind
you in v for vendetta
uh it's where the government created a
virus and used it to seize power over
its people
and there was one incident of police
brutality that sparked a national
protest
and led a larger revolt against the
government
we're not there yet yeah that's what's
freaky yeah what happens on january 6th
i'll uh we'll we'll talk about this in
greater detail i don't want to deal with
the conversation but let me just say man
what happens on january 5th when the
democrats win in georgia assuming they
do
and then all these trump supporters here
the democrats now control everything
and they're in dc and they're angry they
got nothing to lose they're desperate
their property's gone their businesses
are gone their savings is gone
i'll tell you this man it's all tied
together it's just like vendetta where
he says i could see it all tied together
like you know web or whatever
you've got people i remember watching a
video
wait wait let me slow down i went to a
bunch of trump rallies 2015 2016
and i met a bunch of people who were
voting for trump some of them were
bernie sanders supporters
when the democrats gave it to hillary
took it from bernie some of them went to
trump they said because bernie and trump
were the only ones talking about the
trade agreements and bringing back these
jobs
i remember talking to one dude who was
probably like early 50s
and he was saying you know this was in
janesville wisconsin and he was talking
about how his job was gone gone overseas
and trump's talking about bringing these
factories back and bringing back you
know his livelihood his town and that's
what he's voting for
and then i remember seeing a video from
a couple years like a year and a half or
so into trump's presidency
it was a dude crying he was like a
middle-aged guy crying saying before
trump
i lost my job my savings has completely
diminished my my the college fund for my
kids was was we were eating into it
and i knew that not only was i on the
verge of not giving my kids a future
we were on the verge of homelessness
until trump came in
and started putting in these rules these
tariffs negotiating these trade
agreements
and then my companies these companies
start coming back to my area he's like
now i'm working again now i'm saving
again
now i know that i have my safety net
back and it's thanks to donald trump the
guy was in tears
not bawling is out like crying but he
was like you know his tears coming on
facebook he's like thank you donald
trump you've saved my life i can't
believe it
i imagine that video and i've talked
about that one so many times over the
past several years there's one guy
having his life turn around or the
people in michigan when the car factory
started coming back and reinvesting in
the detroit area now those people are
being told
it's all being taken away from you
remember the episode of south park where
carmen gets a million dollars you see
that one
he gets a million dollars and he buys a
theme park with it and then
kyle is all like you know why it's not
fair god why would you give cartman the
worst person in the world a million
dollars
but then cartman loses the million
dollars and he's miserable and he's
crying and he's screaming
i'm not trying to equate the
hard-working people derek hartman don't
get me wrong i'm just saying
you have people who are desperate and
donald trump comes in and in 2019 we get
the best economy of our lives
so says jim kramer if you take his word
for it these people are getting their
jobs back they're getting back on track
then covet hits the democrat governors
destroy everything shut it all down
take away your job take away your
property your chance at life and now
you're going back
backwards now we got cnbc story says
they interviewed a hundred investors
like wealth management funds
two-thirds believe under biden the
economy is gonna tank or it's gonna
start going down it's gonna get bad
now these people are watching everything
being stripped away
are they going to show up in dc and are
they going to be really really angry
kind of think so i mean it can go either
way
but until people i don't see this issue
being resolved until people really
understand what the hell is going on you
know it's
it's not just you know i get it he
thought trump was the the nuke in the
system i'd never
assumed that never thought that he was
never supported him i mean i say that
for any politician
for that matter but the the the idea
that
the these institutions continue to grow
in power and that clue that includes
trump you know with his
executive orders that's going to set the
scene up precedent being set for joe
biden to come and basically do the same
thing
um just may not be working out to these
people's benefit
so this is why i if it keeps going that
route
the the most peaceful way is to me a
separation
like this this idea that we all have to
share this one government though we hate
each other to this point
makes no sense whatsoever this is why
they're control freaks they're control
freaks it's like
it's not about uh people being free i
don't care what
dumb crap they throw out there acting as
if they give give a crap about someone
being
free uh in liberty and all these
concepts no matter what side of the
political spectrum that they claim to be
on
the issue here is that these folks have
this power right this
territorial monopoly right on use of
force violence and ultimate decision
making and they say
we want that and we want to implement
that we want do you
utilize that to implement these crazy
things that you see going on
shutting folks down doing whatever it is
and it's always
claiming to be benefiting the people
that are around them this is why i say
at some point
maybe this isn't working that doesn't
mean even once we split we can't have
have a deal that says okay you got my
back i got yours but we're not
sharing a government it makes no sense
for us to share government well weeks
ago i was talking about this and
talking about a peaceful divorce and
people are like you're crazy
now i see more and more people talking
about it because when you look at the
government
it really looks like there's elements
that are trying to take away people's
ability to fend for themselves
absolutely especially with the latest
news from the irs today
that is planning a 50 increase in audits
of small businesses
the iowa businesses small businesses yes
the irs is literally hiring
additional staff right now to conduct 50
more audits on small businesses
literally wiping out anyone who survived
and was left over
to get there again again meanwhile
amazon walmart allowed to be open they
barely taxes themselves
how many how many audits do they do per
year on small breaks i got to look at
the
i don't know because i think the
important question is if what if they
only do 10 audits
i'm just saying what if what if out of
out of you know we got three we got 100
we got
225 working people in this country how
many of them own small businesses
it's an important question to ask how
many audits do they do because 50
that's a percentage either way either
way i i i think it's well yeah i mean
the problem is it's like they're going
after the
i don't want to defend it i know i don't
know the idea is obviously that they're
going after the little guy after the
little guys that have been
utterly destroyed this this past year
that's what they've been doing so i get
it i totally
understand why someone would you know
look at that and i was like hate the iss
and look at that and be like
you know what hey man what are y'all
doing but no
like there's something wrong with this
and the minute i can get americans
to understand that the better off we're
going to be but a lot of them are
control freaks a lot of them just want
they it's not about liberty it's about
more so control so i want to be able to
force that person
on the other side of the aisle to do
what i want them to do
and they can't they can't see a world
where it's like okay why don't you go do
that and i'm just going to go
go do that that sounds crazy this is the
thing right you got states like wyoming
that's the this the tr the the most
trump state in the country
granted they only have like 550 million
people um 550
000 people not a million in the state
that'd be a massive state by the way no
no 550 000 people in that state so it's
not the biggest
it's it's the most trump support of any
state and then i think west virginia
it doesn't make sense that they're going
to pass you know joe biden wants to ban
all online sales of ammo of ammo
accessories and guns i'm like well that
might make sense for new york we talked
about it
you know what do you what do you do if
someone's breaking into your little
concrete cubicle it smells like sour
milk
maybe it doesn't make sense to fire you
know 556 which might go through the wall
but people will might do it if they're
if they just have it so then there's
questions about
density but if you're in west virginia
if you're in wyoming
it definitely makes sense to have you
know an ar-15 when you're dealing with
animals in fact i don't even know
depending on which which are using what
what kind of ammo can use
might not even be able to actually stop
a large bear or some animal that's
attacking your home you might need some
serious firepower for that
so in new york they're like these
politicians say we need to ban all these
guns how stupid must you be to have like
a
458 you know socom or 450 bushmaster or
something
in new york city and then somebody who's
in the middle of the wilderness is like
are you nuts i definitely need that
stopping power and that's
why is that law gonna affect them right
but that and that's the problem like why
do we have this set up where everybody
can pac uh
pack up whether it be in washington or
wherever they're they're at
and they can vote law vote in laws or
rather legislation that can impact
people in wyoming that doesn't make
sense that doesn't make any sort of
sense when you break it down like that
but we just for the longest have
accepted it like
that's what it is i think right now what
we're seeing is how much of a problem it
actually is
when you get people that are ruled over
by folks that they hate
so that like we saw that definitely over
the last four years how the leftists
just went utterly insane
because a guy never mind he's actually
probably more like them
than any republican president right
right
they don't even understand that but just
that's why they hate them maybe that's
maybe that's they see
they see an image of themselves right
coming into fruition
but no that's the problem and uh i think
that we have to realistically talk about
that as a legitimate solution like
why does it have to be that we all share
this particular government and it's a
lot easier we accept the idea that it's
a lot easier for
uh americans to fight the like federal
government as opposed to let's say the
i don't know the united nations or
something like that and it's obviously
a lot easier for me being out of uh
texas to
fight the texas government as opposed to
the federal government why is it that we
all have to share this government just
like because we don't
yeah i'll put it this way right there's
there's definitely
too much federalization happening
because we could have one federal
government so long as the
states had you know more guarantees and
more protections the problem is
the battle is increasingly over the
national control
the damage nobody cares about their
local politicians
their city falls to crap and so they
talk about voting for someone for
congress and i'm like but congress is
federal voting not local yeah you want
someone to clean up your state what are
your state representatives
you want better representation where you
live and you got to vote locally and
that's why
i think that the complete removal of
that would have people focusing
like people be more narrowly focused on
what's around them as opposed to acting
like
bernie sanders is going to save their
life but that's how it used to be
it used to be that the the president was
chosen for the most part
this is the figurehead well the the the
legislature of the states
ultimately you know we're deciding who
was going to be the elector
for the state and that the senators were
voted on by i believe it was the
legislature it was it was appointment
essentially
they started changing these rules to
make it more about popular vote popular
vote
to make america more of one federalized
nation than individual states
it doesn't work in the long run and it
doesn't work in europe either
the crazy thing is we've been a country
for a lot longer than the european
union's been around
but one of the biggest problems because
i've been all over europe
and i hear from a lot of people in spain
i'm in spain i've been to germany i've
been in the netherlands i've been to the
uk been in france
they tell me at greece one of the
challenges i was i was in greece and i
was asking this dude
he was uh dr who's an uber driver and he
was talking about how the economy is
really really bad it's really hard to
make any money and i was like but can't
you just move to like london and he goes
i'm greek i don't want to move to london
and i was like but it's the eu you know
you could go and
the jobs are better than like no i'm i'm
greek man i'm not british
they don't view themselves the same way
they don't want to live under the same
rules they want to eat the same food
they're very different people and
there's nothing wrong with that
no for sure right right but that's the
just to finish my point right right the
u.s
it's very very similar yeah people in
west virginia want to go hunting with
their
gigan it's a different place but i know
you can say this because you've traveled
and you i know you especially luke
we can all say this for those of us that
travel you can be in
even certain parts of a state and it's
like night and day
like i i lived in corpus christi corpus
christi is nothing like dallas fort
worth
for those of you for those of you that
don't know and unfortunately because of
this
hyper emphasis on like uh they they talk
about this diversity thing right and it
has nothing to do with thought or
anything like that what they really want
is this
different colors and different genders
of people saying the same thing
yes right that's exactly what they want
but
what i where i've been i've has gotten
me in trouble a lot like i embrace those
differences there's nothing wrong with
the fact that people
in that on that side of the country they
just act different they're culturally
different they're what they what they
value is a little different
so again why is it that we're trying to
do this one that was the problem with
covert we saw this
it was a one-size-fits-all approach why
are we treating new york
i mean at some point it was kind of a
shift but why was new york being treated
like texas
like it's not the same like they don't
how they live even
even in new york like upstate versus new
york city they're not the same
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you